Sometimes we meet people who just don't like us.
And, it may be our fault.
You stabbed me!
Or you may have done absolutely nothing wrong.
No matter how much you want everyone to like you,
some people just won't.
Unless you're a magician...
everyone loves a magician.
Do you want to see a magic trick?
Sure.
Close your eyes.
But what is up with this constant need to be liked,
even by people that we don't know?
Yeah, can you have the delivery guy
tell me that...
I'm really funny?
I get that humans are social creatures,
and evolution's kind of made us this way
Ugh, insert religious comment war here.
But you have to get to the point
where you just say, "fuck it."
I mean, I used to be a huge people pleaser.
And I would be so upset and hurt
when someone didn't like me!
And I would be like, "wait, it's just cause you don't know me!
You just need to know me to like me!"
And I'd try extra hard to be nice to them
and win them over.
And it just turned out to be a giant fucking waste of time.
Cause, unfortunately, once someone passes judgment on you,
there's not much you can do about it.
And as... *makes weird noise* as it sounds...
as long as you like who you are
and you love yourself...
that should be enough.
Alright, well, I will see you guys next Monday.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
Oh my god. I'm getting a little too buff.
It's getting a little gross, I'd say.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, that's disgusting but really hot at the same time.